yo this video is brought to you by
square space helping you make beautiful
websites quickly and easily
this week we Beast and through the
darkness with the Wrinkle in Time by
Madeleine L'Engle
this night dark and stormy as [ __ ] and
little meg Murphy can't get no sleep
girl got all kind of mess running
through her dough
a lot of Bulls going down with haters at
school but most of all her daddy's been
missing for over a year and ain't nobody
know we're here so she had downstairs or
her little bro Charles Wallace be
chillin hard brother like I was
expecting you girl and got some milk
eating up with your name what it's like
this cat can read minds or something
mama come rolling in when all of a
sudden over there pup star Mad Dog and
someone that is done who is it oh damn
it's some reg hood rat looking lady
named Miss Watson who tight with Charles
Wallace when she tell Meg's mama that
the tesseract is real mama just bounce
pants later an egg and Charles Wallace
crew up with the campus Big Dawg Calvin
okie on their way to hit up mrs.
Watson's busted ass crib apparently
Calvin itching a hit up the spot even
though he'll know why so the three of
them drop by
knock knock the dough open up all
creepy-like and he peeps some little
hair getting there so long this turns
out it's some other raggedy-ass bitty
name mrs. foo this BZ say them kids best
rest up and get some munchies cuz they
bout to go on an adventure to help Meg's
dead that night Calvin gave his grub on
at the Murray digs and man tell him that
her dad used to be a government
physicist working on top-secret missions
Calvin started to get a little sweet on
Meg and just when she bout to get hot
Charles mrs. whatsit mrs. Pugh and the
voice of their homegirl mrs. witch bust
in and say pack your [ __ ] we're gonna go
save pops and Zoop they wrinkle through
space and land they asses on the planet
Uriel where they be a bunch of crazy
half-horse half-man aliens and what do
you know
all three of them janky biddies are
secretly one of them so they hop up on
Miss Watson and take a little tour of
the planet as they cruisin the kids big
game and
big evil cloud of Darkness that's been
tripping up the universe since back when
since our warp to another planet and
Orion's belt and visit the happy medium
a girl rocking the fly as rolled with a
crystal ball she's showing a vision of
the earth getting wrecked by the
darkness where it is a bunch of artists
scientists and holy rollers like Jesus
been trying to buck the darkness for a
long-ass time the only way to kill the
darkness is for a star to later whoop on
apparently miss Watson used to be a star
back in the day but she then blow
herself up trying to fight the darkness
and that's why she rollin a [ __ ] form
these days just before they piece out
the three doves give the kids some gifts
since they ain't gonna be able to join
them at the next stop so blowing onto
planet Camazotz where everybody look and
act the exact same cousins called hit
they all skipping clapping and bouncing
balls and rhythm with each other creepy
so they roll up to the central
intelligence building and check some
dude with red eyes who be hypnotizing
these suckas minds dudes say he know
what mags daddy yet so Charles Wallace
sack up and strikes a deal with this
fool he'll give in to the dude spell and
get his ass hypnotized if he showed
Megan Cowell would Papa Marie be so
Charles get all zombified and lead them
to dead like being held in a swim cuz he
was too trill to get brainwashed like
everybody else
using the Flyers shades missus who gave
her Meg busses her daddy out they may
all swing over to the spot where it the
big brain that controlling everybody's
mind be the closer they get the mold
control it got over their minds so Papa
Marie snatch up them kids and wrinkle
out of that trash but Charles Wallace
gets left behind
damn them down they land on a planet
Esha set Meg fillers straight cuz their
dad couldn't protect her and they will
wrinkle it through the dark thing
lucky for them though the nasty look at
homies on this planet our friendliest
hell one of them creatures cures Meg and
she start calling her on Beast then them
three half horse hotties drop in and Meg
like can y'all hook me up and get
Charles Wireless
and they like the hell you think this is
girl man recognize that it gotta be
heard I save Charlie dubby I've to mrs.
what to give Magda give me love she get
off her lazy ass and wrinkled over to
where Charles II she dropped in at its
crib and recognized that the one thing
she got that it don't is love
so she focus all her love of CW and free
him from that hivemind hater then they
walk back to earth and reunite with the
whole famine their garden where the
three doves chug up the juice and
disappear into the wind
one of the things this book preaching at
your boy Sparky know plenty bout is that
you can't judge a book by its cover
now I mean all throughout this text
things seeing one way but they actually
the opposite for one young kids dog and
oh mrs. Watson saying she looked like
some nappy Street shrink at the
beginning but later they figured out she
really a horse hunting that's one of the
most beautiful things they done Pete and
suddenly before the children was a
creature more beautiful than any meg had
ever imagined the beauty lay in far more
than the outward description outwardly
mrs watson was surely no longer on this
is what she was a marble white body with
the perfection of dignity and virtue and
exaltation of joy and don't stop there
cuz that boy Charlie dub got all these
haters saying he's stupid cuz he don't
talk much but on the real that do you
got Chad Drake at first cameras lights
seem like a pretty chill spot but when
you look closer there'd be some crazy
brain wise just going down even though
that red eyed scrub sound all nice and
gentle he ain't got them red eyes cuz he
plays it mm-hmm
he crooked as they come and when they
hit the scene at he shall dumb beasts
these little wagons like they bout to
boot up and shake a brother but it ain't
like that yo
they Hill up mad like some of the
realest woods you've ever seen keeping
it real ain't always easy when you stick
out from the crowd though sometimes it
feel better to just blend in with the
all the bullsh like Carolyn do he only
able to roll with the top dogs at school
cuz he hide his real self but like you
say that ain't really him you're good at
school
everybody likes you for all the most
unimportant reasons Calvin said there
hasn't been anybody anybody in the world
I can talk to sure I can function on the
same level as everybody else I can hold
myself down but it isn't me
likewise meg always trippin cuz she
ain't fit in with all the other kids at
school like she's sealing page 17 she
hates being a hardball but when she'd
get a load of Artem identical drones up
and cameras lights she recognized that
if everyone was the same life would suck
a fat one you gotta embrace what makes
you different from anybody else you hurt
on Camazotz we're all happy because
we're all alike
differences create problems you know
that don't you dear sister no meg said
oh yes you do
you've seen that home how true it is you
know that's the reason that happy at
school because you're different I'm
different and I'm happy Calvin said but
you pretend that you are different I'm
different and I like being different
yeah all these kids got any problems but
instead of fixing themselves like some
hoods and other bugs be doing they
realized that as long as your homies got
you and you show each other love you
ain't got to change nothing about
yourself and it's cuz of this that they
able to come together and beats through
the darkness they only got each other
they also got a bigger power at their
back when ever get to real the thing
that allowed them to keep on the hustle
it's some legit Bible talk not only was
Jesus one of the old G's bucking the
dark thing but characters are always
slinging Bible verses at each other
Calvin reads Genesis the Charles Wallace
mrs. whatsit lays down a passage from
the Brin thien's as a gift of Meg they
even save them three horse biddies are
like guardian angels look you ain't got
to be the hardest hood on a block to put
evil in this place all you need is your
homies by your side the Lord in your
heart and love for yourself
if you got that not even the most
twisted evil can touch you yo thanks for
keeping it 100 with me today hey thanks
for watching y'all you know it's
important players showing off your
skills and there's no better way to do
it than with a fly website made with my
boys at Squarespace Squarespace has made
it
easy for anyone to create a smoking
website and they're giving all ul red
barlas 10% off your first order when you
use the offer code thug notes they have
all the tools for you to show off just
how old G you are and Squarespace is
hooking y'all up go to Squarespace comm
slash thug notes or use the link in the
description below to sign up today and
you'll get a free 14 day trial to test
it out be sure to use the offer code
thug notes and you'll get 10% off your
order catch you next time peace